welcome to GK Essentials where we
explore Basics and useful tips for
getting up and running with gke
kubernetes is the top container
orchestration platform for managing
containerized apps including web
services and batch workloads like data
processing machine learning and
scientific simulations
in this video we'll explore why gke is
the perfect choice for your batch
platform
[Music]
batch workloads consist of multiple
tasks that run automatically and finish
without user input these tasks or jobs
get processed in a queue according to
their arrival ensuring efficient
resource usage and minimizing idle time
for the batch processing platform
typically in a batch processing platform
users submit jobs with the program data
and requirements like the CPU and
Hardware accelerator specs after
receiving a confirmation and unique ID
for tracking users are notified when the
job is done and provided with the
outputs or results gke has what it takes
to be the platform for your batch
processing needs let's explore GK batch
enabling features batch workloads often
has significant Hardware requirements GK
supports a variety of compute engine VM
series to fulfill a variety of Hardware
needs including cost optimized balanced
scale out memory compute and accelerator
optimized options these VMS are
available with various CPU platforms
like arm Intel and AMD processors for
special compute intensive workloads like
video processing or AIML GK also
supports Hardware accelerators like gpus
and tpus tpus are Google's custom Asics
which can help you speed up machine
learning tasks
as we have explored in the past videos
gke supports massive scale with up to 15
000 node clusters allowing customers
like bear Corp science to process 15
billion genotypes per hour
GK uses a concept of node pools to
organize Hardware which caters to
various workload needs while the cluster
Auto scaler adjusts node count in each
pool automatically based on demand
simply set the minimum and maximum pool
size and GK handles the rest using the
optimize utilization profile unused
nodes are removed faster helping control
costs GK also has features to maximize
your workloads availability for example
Regional clusters provide a highly
available control plane and node pools
replicated across multiple zones node
Auto Repair ensures healthy running
nodes by initiating repairs after
consecutive failed l-checks node Auto
upgrades keep your cluster nodes up to
date with the control plane version
during updates
make sure to check out our video on GK
upgrades to learn more about the
upgrades features and controls that
allow you to maximize your uptime across
cluster upgrades need to share your
clusters with multiple users no problem
GK supports multi-tenancy allowing you
to separate tenants and their resources
into different namespaces you can
enforce policies for tenant isolation
set quotas and even track cost
allocations batch workloads are often
resource intensive workloads GK enables
you to control resource consumption by
assigning resource quotas part-tenant
and processing jobs in order with q a
kubernetes native job queuing system
designed for batch workloads
new manages quotas and job admission
deciding when jobs should wait start or
be preempted Q introduces Concepts like
cluster queue governing resource pools
and resource flavors representing
resource variations
cluster queues can borrow unused codas
from cohorts and resource flavors
associate variations with nodes through
labels and paints you can find resources
to learn more about queue in the
description below GK uses compute Indian
persistent disk for durable storage
through persistent volumes with regional
mode offering access to the same storage
across zones local ssds serve as High
Performance Scratch space for batch
workloads reduce costs and optimize
compute instances with hyperdisc
throughput persistent disk family
allowing Dynamic throughput and capacity
provisioning with gke provision
throughput is met on any scheduled node
batch workloads can utilize Google Cloud
Storage Cloud file Store Pub sub and
bigquery for data management and
Communications gk's compact placement
policy places nodes in closer proximity
for low latency high performance
workloads customized node configuration
and tuning parameters for your workloads
like TCP socket buffer values improve
latency sensitive workloads with busy
polling and network profiles increase
Network bandwidth using Google Virtual
Nic for high performance applications a
useful tool for managing costs for more
flexible batch workloads is spot VMS
this preemptable VMS offer lower prices
without guaranteed availability
with GPU time sharing and multi-instance
GPU you can get more out of your GPU
notes in gke
time sharing is a gke feature that lets
multiple containers share a single
physical GPU attached to a node
multi-instance gpus allow you to
partition a single Nvidia a100 GPU in up
to 7 slices each slice can be allocated
to one container on the Node
independently predictable workloads can
benefit from Google Cloud reservations
and committed use discounts yielding
significant savings for example you
could create a node pool with reserved
instances and prioritize its usage then
set up additional on-demand and spot VM
node pools to handle overflow jobs at a
lower cost as needed
GK also offers image streaming allowing
workloads to initialize without waiting
for the entire container image to
download improving initialization times
and cost efficiency
monitoring is important for any workload
GK integrates with Google Cloud
operation Suite enabling control over
logs and metrics sent to Cloud logging
and Cloud monitoring this provides batch
users with detailed up-to-date
information on cluster and batch
workloads GK supports managed service
for Prometheus offering hassle-free
metrics collection with Google's Monarch
time series database manage collection
simplifies Prometheus server management
check out our video on managed service
for Prometheus Link in the description
below to learn more the cloud operation
Suite also features Cloud operations
monitoring dashboards giving an overview
of GK cluster and resource utilization
with drill down and filtering options
not only do these monitors enable you to
see what's going on in your cluster at a
variety of useful levels they also help
you meet the goals by providing tooling
to manage service level objectives for
applications running on the cluster in
this video you have learned about GK
features for compute storage monitoring
and more that make gks scalable
resilient secure and cost effective
platform for running batch workloads
with GK at your fingertips we can't wait
to see what awesome ml applications or
scientific discoveries they can make to
get started with gke you can check out
the Google Cloud console by visiting the
links below the description also has
links to more details on many of the
features we covered today and stay tuned
for our next videos where we dive deeper
into GK topics foreign
[Music]
foreign